In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 13, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr, Akilina.
On the 13th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr, Akilina.
Saint Akilina was the daughter of Otholmios, an eminent man of Biblos in Phoenicia.
She was baptized at the age of five by Bishop Otholios,
and from the age of ten taught her companions with such zeal to turn from idolatry and to Christ,
that she was denounced by a certain Nicodemus, to Volusian, the Proconcil,
who had been charged by Emperor Diocletian to apply his first edicts of persecution in this region.
She fearlessly confessed the name of the Savior before the Magistrate,
who, with no pity for her youth, ordered that she be beaten with rods and red-hotalls thrust into her ears.
Left for dead outside the town, an angel went to succure her,
and, tricking the guards' surveillance, she got through to Volusian's bedroom.
Waking in terror with a jump, he called for help, accusing the saint of having used witchcraft,
and had her beheaded the next day.
Her precious relics were then translated to Constantinople to a church near the Forum,
which was dedicated to her, and where she enjoyed great veneration.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.